[Applauso]
bene buonasera tutte e tutti
meraviglioso essere qua città
meravigliosa luogo meraviglioso pubblico
meraviglioso
parliamo di
lifelong e tech quindi di apprendimento
di tecnologia
di tecnologia al servizio
dell'apprendimento non è un argomento
molto amato in italia
abbiamo qua una platea di età variabile
quindi sapete di cosa parlo
ma è un tema chiave per lo sviluppo
sostenibile nel nostro paese
partiamo proprio dal concetto di
sostenibilità parola abusatissima quanto
ne abbiamo sentito parlare negli ultimi
mesi paio d'anni in realtà si sente
parlare per slogan
gigi agenda 20 30
quanti suoni gol dell'agenda 20 30
17 non è ovvio bravi bravi
bene ho già un punto a favore
17 gol si parla tanto di ecologia di
energia si parla pochissimo di cosa
voglia dire sostenibilità
sostenibilità dal latino
sostenere tenere sotto
supportare e sostenere
difendere ma che bello è difendere
difendere cose al nostro futuro
sostenibilità
e dal mio punto di vista forse dobbiamo
un po smettere di aspettare che siano
gli altri occuparsi di sostenibilità a
realizzarla ea io amo tradurre il
termine sostenibilità in responsabilità
individuale quindi farsi carico delle
proprie piccole grandi azioni quotidiane
per il bene comune è ma questo da cosa
nasce
nasce dall educazione
dall'educazione
termine un po poco usato in italia vero
in italia si usa istruzione
mettere dentro invece io amo il termine
educazione tirare fuori a tirare fuori
talenti
tirare fuori il potenziale
educare dal verbo e ducere
il meraviglioso team organizza di
organizzazione di te decs mia sito una
lettera
trasformare gli specchi in finestre ecco
cosa vuol dire educare bene dei tanti
gol di 17 gol dell'agenda 20 30 dell'onu
ce ne sono due particolarmente e che mi
stanno a cuore il primo il gol 4 pochi
li conoscono è
gol 4 educazione di qualità malamente
tradotti in italiano istruzione di
qualità io amo tradurlo ovviamente
educazione di qualità
che dice garantire un'educazione
di qualità equa inclusiva e promuoverà
per opportunità di apprendimento
permanente per tutte e tutti il tu te
l'ho aggiunto io potete immaginarlo
il gol 4 è un sogno un sogno no pensate
alla nostra scuola
due secondi di silenzio per la nostra
scuola
pensate alle opportunità di
apprendimento costante per tutti
scegliete voi quanti secondi pensarci
l'educazione di qualità è veramente un
sogno ma è la vera garanzia della
sostenibilità
garanzia di futuro garanzia di civiltà
insieme un altro gol di cui tutti
parlano
col 5 parità di genere
e di nuovo a me piace reinterpretarlo
come accettazione della diversità
diversità come opportunità e la
montessori che diceva ognuno impara con
i propri modi i propri tempi io amo
aggiungere siamo tutti i bisogni
educativi speciali
siamo tutti diversi
siamo meravigliosamente diversi e questo
noi non semplici viene riconosciuto
naturalmente è anche difficile parlo da
madre anche difficile ricordarcelo gol 4
e gol 5 a supporto del nostro futuro a
sostegno del nostro futuro a garanzia di
una vera sostenibilità
cosa è successo cent'anni fa
data storica per l'italia
meno sapete
riforma della
prima grande e io aggiungo unica riforma
della scuola in italia vinse gentile
rispetto enriquez noi siamo il frutto di
cento anni
di visione strategica di gentile è che
ci ha voluto umanisti contro le materie
scientifiche ha relegato alle materie
scientifiche ai tecnici ai geni naturali
a pochi
e poi noi adesso ci ritroviamo o no che
siamo ultimi nelle classifiche
diciamo mal posizionati nelle
classifiche sulle competenze
scientifiche ci mancano gli ingegneri
insomma disallineamento totale rispetto
alle esigenze non solo di lavoro che è
importante non solo di lavoro ma anche
nella vita quotidiana
l'educazione finanziaria non nota e così
via
hanno avuto una forte visione strategica
hanno fatto grandi cose ma noi siamo il
frutto di cent'anni in cui nulla è
cambiato
siamo andati avanti con questo fardello
dopo cento anni di nuovo ancora manca
una visione strategica
chi è che parla di scuola chi è che
parla di studenti chi è che parla del
futuro dell'italia cosa deve essere
l'italia fra vent'anni
quindi
un po di piccole azioni
magari anche tanti investimenti ma non
c'è visione non c'è una strategia
ci sono attività piani cose che vengono
fatte
nel mondo nel mondo l'hanno capito
ovviamente con quei paesi più di un
archi di altri per carità l'hanno capito
che la tecnologia può essere al servizio
dell'educazione che l'educazione è un
settore chiave per lo sviluppo dei paesi
non è un caso che finlandia singapore
non è un caso e tutto pensato
strategia piani d'azione risultati ma
anche investimenti
qualche numero veloce 34 unicorni nel
mondo è tech quindi nel settore della
tecnologia
dedicata appunto alle ducation 34
unicorni la maggior parte naturalmente
stati uniti cina india 2 in europa
ovviamente nessuno in italia
2.500 start up e tech in europa
ultimo round investimento di una startup
austriaca a 300 milioni
piattaforma di più preda tutor in online
questo è il mondo il mondo che si muove
veloce velocissimo non guarda indietro
guarda avanti no noi siamo nati
nell'altro secolo i ragazzi e le ragazze
i 10 milioni di ragazzi e ragazze
italiane che vanno a scuola sono nati in
questo millennio
l'italia mi hanno detto che non c'è
nessuno unicorno a per chi non lo
sapesse un ricordo e una società non
quotata che vale più di un miliardo di
dollari scusate l'inciso
nessuno unicorno e
150 start up nelle tech credo che una di
queste
non siamo un mercato piccolo è 60
milioni di abitanti cioè non è che siamo
in mano il paesino piccolino siamo un
grande paese che ha una grande
tradizione culturale no ce lo diciamo
sempre grandioso con situazione
culturale
ha studiate per inciso ultimo
investimento in una società e tech di
cui molto si è parlato quest'estate 7
milioni e mezzo non c'è visione non ci
sono ambizioni vi ricordate 300 milioni
7 milioni e mezzo
numeri i numeri danno l'idea del livello
di ambizione è che abbiamo in italia
eppure in italia dovremmo preoccuparsene
perché noi abbiamo un primato in italia
quello dei neet
not in not in education employment
training più di 3 milioni di ragazze e
ragazzi che non studiano non sono
frequentano corsi di formazione non
lavorano
quindi il risultato di
l'abbandono scolastico del
disallineamento
dell'offerta scolastica rispetto alle
esigenze
dei giovani e del mondo del lavoro
il disallineamento del sud e con
rispetto alle competenze richieste dal
mondo del lavoro
per rendere la cosa ancora un po più
tragica
vuol dire che il 25 per cento dei
giovani tra i 15 e 34 anni sono nate
detto ancora altri numeri uno su quattro
on 23 41 e 34 c a tantissimi è un
disastro è un disastro perché gli
abbiamo tolto il futuro ci stiamo
togliendo rischiamo di togliere il
futuro
not in education employment or training
quindi dovremo occuparcene di questo
lo stop che è enorme 3 milioni più di
tre milioni di persone tra l'altro è uno
stop che viene alimentato costantemente
da questi flussi che annualmente no
costantemente tra l'altro siamo anche
tra i primi per abbandono scolastico
alimento questo numero eppure questo è
la punta di un iceberg
perché perché in realtà
il target del lifelong learning quindi
il target di come utilizzare la
tecnologia a servizio dell apprendimento
o per stare al passo con i tempi per
essere in grado di essere protagonisti
di questo sviluppo sostenibile per
essere responsabili quotidianamente con
le proprie azioni del futuro del nostro
paese
e siamo tutti noi sessanta milioni di
italiani
che hanno bisogno di uno strumento
che
garantisca
apprendimento continuo
continue conoscenze migliorarsi
approfondire ampliare le proprie
conoscenze
con qualità
il digitale la tecnologia lo può
permettere perché hai l'apertura a
tantissimo un'offerta enorme in modo
efficiente quindi con dei costi ridotti
con dei costi contenuti eviti gli
spostamenti per esempio ma soprattutto e
qui mi viene a dire che gli arrivano
soprattutto su misura un apprendimento
finalmente individuale sempre più
individuale perché alla fine ciascuno di
noi impara con i propri modi i propri
tempi siamo tutti i bisogni educativi
speciali
ciascuno alle proprie preferenze
i propri modi e il digitale permette una
flessibilità enorme unica non dico che
la tecnologia debba essere esclusiva sto
dicendo semplicemente che può e deve
essere usata a servizio di un'educazione
efficace e continua efficiente di
qualità su misura
il target siamo tutti noi
e la tecnologia della tecnologia evolve
finora parlo per l'italia siamo stati
estremamente timidi
nell'usarla l'abbiamo sconsiderata più
l'abbiamo in generale come nazione un
pericolo un ostacolo una difficoltà
una novità fastidiosa eppure tutti la
usano normalmente ormai per prenotare e
pagare bonifici e così via magari non
tutti però insomma è molto diffuso
l'utilizzo ed è molto veloce la
diffusione di questo utilizzo
però la tecnologia sta correndo corre
veloce e adesso abbiamo il metaverso
metaverso che ha un potenziale enorme di
fare la differenza
perché perché è ancora più una
tecnologia su misura dei singoli
individui
cosa ne pensate
siamo ottimisti
c'è uno che dice di no
stiamo a vedere
dal mio punto di vista si parte sempre
dalla strategia dalla visione cosa deve
diventare l'italia fra 20 anni cosa come
vogliamo
garantire la sostenibilità il futuro una
crescita sostenibile
vi lascio con la domanda il metaverso fa
la differenza e vi auguro buon
apprendimento a tutti
[Applauso]